hey leute aufgrund einer privaten
diskussion über diese mundschutz dinge
mit denen ja aktuell halb deutschland
rumrennt und die ja auch wirklich
nützlich sind habe ich mir die frage
gestellt ist es wirklich so schwierig
zurzeit an vernünftigen mundschutz zu
einem vernünftigen preis zu kommen in
deutschland selber werden erst seit
kürzester zeit mundschutzmasken von
nationalen unternehmen hergestellt und
wenn masken im ausland bestellt werden
verschwinden sie halten schnell mal
irgendwo in kenia am flughafen 20 euro
noch hinauf variationen tk obwohl gut
das sind zehn stück lieferungen 14 bis
naja gut zurück zum thema in fast allen
apotheken war jegliche form von
mundschutz restlos ausverkauft oder die
hatten halt keine produkte die sie
anbieten konnten gestern habe ich
allerdings in eine apotheke die fp3
maske gesehen allerdings für 25 euro
als wir vor zwei wochen die idee
gekommen ist dieses video zu drehen habe
ich natürlich auch auf amazon
recherchiert da war alles ausverkauft
oder halt erst in einem monat lieferbar
und natürlich auch zu sehr hohen preisen
und dann habe ich irgendwie mal gedacht
wo guckst du mal auf wunsch nach und da
bin ich tatsächlich fündig geworden und
ja da schauen wir uns jetzt mal an so
leute was geht ab genauer gesagt schon
gehört ich war fleißig auf sich aktiv
und habe dort alle masken gekauft die
halt innerhalb der nächsten noch also
ich habe vor eineinhalb wochen bestellt
und alles was halt innerhalb einer woche
geliefert werden kann entweder mit
express versand oder sogar ein paket
habe ich gefunden das mit
standardversand versendet wurde was auch
wirklich extrem schon an kamen keine
ahnung warum das ist irgendwie so ein
neues system da es war trotzdem schon
ziemlich teuer
alles in allem für so masken muss man
sagen aber gut habe ich damit gerechnet
hier kurse zum beispiel eine maske 90
cent ich habe fünf genommen für 15 euro
30 halten mit expressversand dann
innerhalb der nächsten woche eigentlich
ist hat sich das noch ein bisschen raus
gezögert bei mir ging's schneller aber
vielleicht kommt das ja auch schneller
an ich weiß nicht warum ich nicht direkt
zehn ausgewählt habt keine ahnung
bisschen dumm aber zu den masken erzählt
später noch mehr
dann habe ich hier von zehn stück
gekauft in lauf für 14 euro 40 genau die
habe ich auch bestellt plus hier den
expressversand auch den habe ich eben
gar nicht mit einberechnet das heißt wir
waren eben auch nochmal expressversand
sehen
es ist schon ja man muss schon 25 euro
rechnen irgendwie pro produkt und das
hier sind ja wirklich nur diese ganz
einfach masken ja ich habe aber auch
natürlich diese ffp 2 beziehungsweise
fp3 maske bestellt ist ja eigentlich
beides ist gleich also das ist ja wohl
die maske die wirklich den besten schutz
hat da habe ich ein ps bestellt kann man
auch nur ja für neun euro express
versand und elf euro 40 das produkt also
insgesamt auch noch mal 20 euro für eine
maske hohmann und leute die sollte bis
zum 4 april kommen sie ist immer noch
nicht da ja ich bin euch hier super
gerne die bestellbestätigungen oder wo
das auch steht sie ist noch nicht da
das ist ein bisschen schade sonst würde
ich euch dann natürlich auch direkt
zeigen kurze kommentar frage an euch und
zwar habe ich ja diese km 95 masken
bestellt hier wird mir jetzt gezeigt n95
die sehen ja ja so ein bisschen ähnlich
aus bis auf dieses diesem filter hier
sind kann man die gleich setzt auf eine
stufe mit diesem ffp drei masken ich
weiß es nicht schreibt sehr gerne in die
kommentare
dann würde ich davon später auf jeden
fall noch mal einige nachbestellen weil
die kamen wirklich gut an schnell genau
und diese hier habe ich noch mit
standard versand bestellt die kam echt
richtig schnell an ich weiß nicht warum
aber hier für euch vielleicht so 10 eur
17 euro ins zusammen 14 maske kann man
nicht mehr kann
eigentlich schon aber zur aktuellen an
die aktuelle situation angepasst nicht
unbedingt jetzt packen wir erst mal aus
und vielleicht bringe ich dann später
noch ein paar leuten maske vorbei
schauen wir mal viel spaß sollte dann
würde ich sagen machen wir uns mal kurz
ich weiß nicht machen aber bisher so
leute
damit würde ich mal sagen machen wir uns
ans auspacken ich bin mal gespannt ob
das von der qualität her vernünftig ist
also ich gehe zwar davon aus aber man
kann ja nie wissen er ist ja immerhin
von hoffentlich auch wenn ich diesmal
sagen muss zwei pakete sind mit fedex
geliefert worden also weil ich halt
expressversand gewählt habt die kamen
aus china das konnte ja zurück verfolgen
weil irgendwie innerhalb von 4 werktagen
oder so waren die da und dann haben wir
noch die 1
andere paket was mit standardversand
zurückkommen das ist so sieht das dann
zum beispiel aus fedex express das logo
kennt man das ja irgendwie an jedem
flughafen überall
weißt du was das interessante ist
anfällig slogan ja hier in der frei
das weiß man also es wird doch
ausgezeichnet zum besten liga der welt
oder so nur wegen diesen teil oder das
habe ich nämlich auch irgendwo gelesen
gut während ich das jetzt auf mache er
wollte man es ganz kurz
was sagen und zwar und zwar wenn ich auf
diese ganze idee gekommen weil mein papa
der arbeitet ich bin jetzt nicht genau
sagen was er macht aber in sondern
sozialen einrichtungen und da haben also
diese sozialen einrichtungen die müssen
ja weiterhin am laufen bleiben weil sich
da um menschen gekümmert wird ja die
haben pfleger ist eigentlich wie ein
altenheim wo kann man sagen und wenn
irgendein kroner fall geoutet haben wir
natürlich ein riesen problem weil es
muss sich ja irgendwie um diese menschen
gekümmert werden und für dieses für
diese soziale einrichtungen es gab
einfach keine masken die sind nicht
anmassen gekommen und das ist auch
anscheinend wie ich jetzt gerade auch
bei instagram gelesen habt weil mir sehr
viele von euch geschrieben haben auf
meine story dass es bei extrem vielen
einrichtungen so ist das einfach die
massen fehlen also da sind jeden tag
ganz viele menschen offen haufen die
sich um irgendwen kümmern und haben halt
keinen zugang zu diesen massen was
natürlich sehr schade ist weswegen ich
auch die ganzen masken natürlich nicht
selber behalten werde sondern weiter
geben werde
zum einen an die eigentlichen kommt mein
papa aber auch an irgendwas anderes weil
das sind ja ein gut genug gelagert bin
ich mal gespannt sagt 13 wenn das
unterschiedliche hier handelt es sich um
die stets ja skn 95 masken keine ahnung
was das bedeutet warum diese hier als
anders verpackt ist als die anderen
beiden weiß ich gar nicht
mich wunderts mal habe ich da wirklich
nur drei bestellt ist wie es ist ach so
zwei stück drin
na gut dann sind das insgesamt schon mal
und hier ist ach so ja okay gut ich habe
fünf anscheinend bestellt ich schätze
mal wie viel ich bezahlt hat 30 und 18
euro und dann noch zehn euro versand
also es ist schon echt krass teuer ich
mache mir diese einzelne hier vorsichtig
auf die anderen welt natürlich
am besten eingeflossen ich habe meine
hände auf gerade noch mal war schon so
sagt ja gut also also die sieht auf
jeden fall schon mal so ich geh jetz
auch sitzen eine kann ich ja auch sehr
bald ne ich hatte noch nie sondern was
glaubst das richtig rund ja natürlich
konnte er irgendwann ein video des
vielleicht haben die doch welche wenn
ich puste kürzel das soll in meinen
augen
naja also ist auf jeden fall von der
qualität her absolut in ordnung deutlich
besser als diese masken mit denen die
menschen draußen rum rennen ja das sind
ja einfach so ganz stimmte also man
braucht eigentlich diesen
sicherheitsstandard fp3 nur sowas na ja
genug gelagert und die haben wir halt
sommer fünf da freue ich mich drüber
kommen wir zum nächsten paket die sind
glaube ich am samstag hier eingetroffen
sogar per standardversand ich habe euch
das ja eben schon am pc gezeigt wie viel
ich da bezahlt habe so ich weiß nicht ob
das so gut ist hält was so paket wieder
angeht dann war das hier auf jeden fall
deutlich besser verpackt aber machen wir
das auch noch vorsichtig heraus also
hier haben wir jetzt insgesamt glaube
ich 10 oder 15 stück 12 34 19 14 stück
das sind ja die dinger die kennt man
auch nötig haben wir sehr viele auf
würde ich mal sagen aber es ist ja
besser als gar nichts auch wenn ich
natürlich von der qualität und der
vertrag nicht so gut sind wie die hier
anscheinend konnte man da irgendwie dran
kommen in deutschland weil ich halt
schon sehr viele leute damit rum laufen
gesehen hat dann schauen wir uns mal das
nächste paket an das ist auch von fedex
ist heute morgen hier eingetroffen habe
ich natürlich auch expressversand
gewählt muss ich gleich mal schauen ich
hab euch wahrscheinlich eben schon
gezeigt wie viel ich dafür bezahlt habt
also es ist man muss sagen es ist alles
andere als günstig und das alles
unterschiedliche ja da kann es auch eine
brauchst du eine punkteskala wir haben
bin ich mit schal und so
zumal wir sind wenigstens gut eingepackt
und von der gleichen marke trifft mal
hier also die kommen auch aus china
wie gesagt wird expressversand es ist
exakt die gleiche menge dass ein anderer
die habe ich jetzt auch wieder zehn
stück bestellt müssen wir gleich mal
schauen welche besser sind entweder die
oder die hier für insgesamt moment 15
euro plus acht euro express versorgen
also insgesamt 23 euro für zehn masken
[Applaus]
gut da tut sich überhaupt nix ich würd
mal sagen vom typ her ist das eigentlich
das gleiche nur dass hier die farbe
haltlos und da nicht nur ich habe euch
ja eben schon gezeigt ich habe ja auch
die fp3 maske bestellt das war die
teuerste noch mal ganz kurz zum
briefkasten vielleicht ist ja jetzt
angekommen weil die hätte eigentlich
schon am vierten april ankommen müssen
das stimmt eigentlich auch sonst immer
kleinen moment nicht schon gedacht weil
wir heute sagten und das nächste die
kommt das stimmt auch an die frage ist
nur wann
der sinn ist ja eigentlich euch zu
zeigen okay was könnte man bestellen
wenn man das jetzt wirklich benötigt was
halt wirklich schnell ankommt aber mit
bisher ist ja die gibt es ja die finde
ich auch am besten nur diese fp3 dinger
sind halt wahrscheinlich noch besser ist
ein bisschen schade weil die hätte ich
sehr gern gehabt und das hier müsste man
auch noch hier sogar blaue kostengründen
keine ahnung wieso also dass hier sind
jetzt noch mal zehn das heißt wir haben
jetzt insgesamt 10 20 30 35 dann fehlt
auch die ft3 maske die ja auch noch
kommt ich habe eben auf instagram dieses
video gepostet was auch fragen wollt und
zwar habe ich hier ganz viele
mundschutzmasken rumliegen wieder dazu
kommt heute später habt ihr eine idee
wenig die spenden sollte also einen
abnehmer habe ich auf jeden fall schon
und da haben sich echt schon sehr viele
drauf gemeldet mit sehr bewegend stories
wieder anhalt beschreiben wie schwer ist
gerade ist so eine maske zurückkommen
will das jetzt nicht genau hier
einbinden aber das weiß ich aber dass
mehreren achten bekommen dass die
krankheit haben oder so und selber nicht
anders gekommen und wenn dann kostet 40
euro ich hab natürlich jetzt auch 35
werde ich jetzt vielleicht gerne zeigen
dass ich noch mal die einen hier die am
besten sind ich glaube diese hier
einfach noch mal zwei mal bestellen und
die dann sozusagen den leuten wie die
benötigen
nämlich wie gesagt auch für meinen papa
damit zur verfügung stellen könnte also
ich meine wenn man jetzt einmal
mitmischen guten was würde es machen
kann dann bin ich natürlich der richtige
ansprechpartner dafür genau also wenn
ihr da irgendwann abnehmer hier in köln
noch habt und schreibt mir gern bei
instagram sonst entscheidet es einfach
selber vielleicht nehme ich das noch mit
tieren dieses video ich weiß nicht genau
oder euch ist ja vielleicht auch ganz
gut zu wissen dass man da noch machst du
bekommt innerhalb von vier tagen zwar
mit expressversand dann nochmal acht
euro oben drauf oder so aber es ist
möglich ich hoffe dass wieder deutlich
gefallen dass mir sehr gerne daumen nach
oben da und was ihr auch noch auf jeden
fall machen kann
die einnahmen die ich mit diesem video
erzähle dass ich davon noch mehrere
masken kauft das wäre ja auch cool da
bin ich auf jeden fall bereit zu dank
fürs zuschauen aber nicht den kanal in
seinem alex wie und wir sehen uns
übermorgen wahrscheinlich wieder gibt's
neues video
haut rein so okay ich habe jetzt noch
mal ganz wichtig dass das waren 34
unterschied 10 von den kn 590 masken
bestellt oder vielleicht geschädigte
sogar zweimal
das heißt weil das waren eigentlich die
besten hier expressversand
ich habe jetzt hier 18 masken drin
und die bringen wir zu einem altersheim
das kann ich das altersheim ist direkt
bei mir hier in der umgebung und die
können auf jeden fall noch ein paar
gebrauchen
[Applaus]
ich habe ja auch schon im zug gesagt
irgendwann in köln kennt oder irgendeine
einrichtung ich habe jetzt auch nicht so
viele wie gesagt aber immer ein paar
dann lass mich das sehr gern auch winzer
wissen schreibt mir doch einfach gerne
habt keine scheu
das war es jetzt im video auf jeden fall
spaß gemacht und ich bin mal gespannt
wann die nächsten ankommen aber 30